DARIUS RUCKER.
[cheers and applause]
[whistling]
- [playing guitar]
♪ DON'T GO OUT
WITH MY FRIENDS NO MORE ♪
♪ DON'T WANNA
HOLD YOUR HAND NO MORE ♪
- HOOTIE, HOOTIE...
[crowd chanting]
HOOTIE, HOOTIE, HOOTIE...
- ♪ AND I DON'T WANNA
BE WITH YOU ♪
all: HOOTIE, HOOTIE,
HOOTIE, HOOTIE...
- NO, NO.
all: HOOTIE, HOOTIE...
- NO, NO, NO, NO.
I'M NOT IN HOOTIE
AND THE BLOWFISH ANYMORE, Y'ALL.
DOING MY OWN THING.
- WHAT DO YOU MEAN "IN HOOTIE"?
BECAUSE YOU ARE HOOTIE, MAN!
COME ON, EVERYBODY!
all: HOOTIE, HOOTIE...
HOOTIE, HOOTIE, HOOTIE...
- NO, NO...
NO, NO, NO, ALL RIGHT,
NOW--NOW--NOW STOP IT, STOP IT.
I'M NOT HOOTIE.
I'M DARIUS RUCKER. ALL RIGHT?
I USED TO BE THE FRONT MAN
FOR A BAND CALLED
HOOTIE AND THE BLOWFISH.
ALL RIGHT,
BUT I WAS NEVER HOOTIE.
THERE WAS NEVER A HOOTIE.
- WAIT,
JUST--IF I MAY--
IF I MAY ASK,
WHERE ARE THE BLOWFISH AT,
RIGHT, GUYS?
COME ON, EVERYBODY!
BLOWFISH!
all: [chanting]
BLOWFISH, BLOWFISH, BLOWFISH...
- NO, NO, NO! THE--
THERE ARE NO PEOPLE KNOWN
AS "THE BLOWFISH," Y'ALL.
OKAY?
THE WHOLE BAND WAS JUST CALLED
HOOTIE AND THE BLOWFISH.
THAT'S IT.
IT WAS A NONSENSE NAME.
LIKE HOOBASTANK.
OR TOAD THE WET SPROCKET.
- OH.
- [plays guitar]
♪ DON'T GO OUT
WITH MY FRIENDS NO MORE ♪
♪ DON'T WANNA
HOLD YOUR HAND NO MORE ♪
- OH! OH!
- WHAT? WHAT IS IT, MAN?
- I SEE. I GET IT NOW.
I UNDERSTAND.
HEY, WE GOTTA PICK, Y'ALL!
WE GOTTA CHOOSE BETWEEN...
- NO, NO...
HOOTIE OR THE BLOWFISH!
SO, WHO WANTS TO SEE
THE BLOWFISH?
[crowd cheers]
- THERE'S NO BLOWFISH.
- AND WHO WANTS
TO SEE HOOTIE?
- HEY.
HEY, THAT--THAT HURTS
MY FEELINGS, Y'ALL.
- YEAH, BUT YOU SAID
YOU WEREN'T HOOTIE.
- NO, I'M NOT, SIR.
BUT IN THE QUESTION
YOU JUST ASKED THE AUDIENCE,
I-I WAS CLEARLY HOOTIE.
- SO YOU ARE HOOTIE!
- I'M NOT, THOUGH.
- HE IS HOOTIE!
- NO...
[crowd cheers]
- HOOTIE, HOOTIE...
all: [chanting]
HOOTIE, HOOTIE, HOOTIE, HOOTIE,
HOOTIE, HOOTIE,
HOOTIE, HOOTIE, HOOTIE...
[crowd cheering]
- [sobbing]
I'M HOOTIE!
I'M HOOTIE! AAH!